les territoires occupés par les forces
russes se dessinent après la route
ses habitants sont désormais dans la
zone contrôlée par les Ukrainiens 3 km à
vol d'oiseau et la sensation d'avoir
échappé de justesse à un piège d'accord
du mois
mais vu la situation
on est parti tout de suite
nous sommes sur le seul checkpoint du
pays qui permet aussi vite de passer des
territoires
occupés par la Russie au territoire
contrôlé par les Ukrainiens toutes les
personnes qui sont en train de sortir
des territoires occupés ici nous ont dit
qu'elles étaient parties dans l'urgence
il y a d'abord la mobilisation décrétée
par le Kremlin et ce référendum jouait
d'avance visant à annexer leur région
ces hommes racontent des urnes portées à
domicile et une organisation qui laisse
assez peu de liberté de choix
ils viennent accompagner d'au moins deux
soldats et parfois abordent un véhicule
avec une mitrailleuse
quand on voit comment se passe le
référendum quand ils vont de maisons en
maison armées ça donne une idée de la
manière dont ils vont nous enrôler
ils vont encercler le village amener le
bus et terminez on aura disparu moi je
préfère mourir pour mon pays que de
crever là-bas au bon vouloir de Poutine
et on peut sortir sans difficulté des
territoires occupés mais pour les hommes
âgés de 18 à 35 ans il est déjà trop
tard
sur le dernier checkpoint
là où les occupants filtres le passage
il nous laisse plus sortir les hommes de
18 à 35 ans
il les bloque
donc le nombre de gens qui arrivent ici
baissent par rapport à la normale alors
qu'on sait que le nombre de gens qui
voudraient partir augmentent
certains retrouvent leurs proches après
une longue séparation d'autres savent
qu'ils ne reverront pas les leurres
avant longtemps resté de l'autre côté du
front